buenas noches eeuu es un honor hablar
para ustedes esta noche desde el fuerte
mckinley el lugar de la batalla que
inspiró las palabras de nuestro himno
nacional esas palabras que han inspirado
esta tierra de héroes en todas las
generaciones y fue en este lugar 206
años atrás
nuestros republicanos lucharon contra un
bombardeo
quisieron dividir nuestra nación y
terminar el experimento estadounidense
los héroes que estuvieron en este fuerte
lucharon con su vida libertad
y la bandera estadounidense
y eso define nuestra nación
pero casi no son nombrados en la
reciente convención demócrata demócrata
lo que hicieron fue atacar durante
cuatro días a eeuu joe biden dijo que
estábamos viviendo una temporada de
oscuridad pero como dijo el presidente
tronco donde yo vaivén de la oscuridad
nosotros vemos la grandeza de eeuu
en estos tiempos difíciles nuestro país
necesita un presidente que crea en eeuu
que crean las capacidades del pueblo
estadounidense encontrarse en nuevos
retos nuevos retos y defender las
libertades que atesoramos eeuu necesita
cuatro años más de presidente
trump en la casa blanca
[Aplausos]
antes de avanzar déjenme decir algo a
las familias
que se verán afectadas por el huracán
laura nuestras oraciones están con
ustedes nuestra administración está
trabajando con las autoridades locales
hemos movilizado
y sus fondos para estos lugares esto es
una tormenta difícil y fuerte
manténganse a salvo y sepan que vamos a
estar con ustedes en cada paso para
apoyarlos rescatar responder y
recuperarnos en los próximos días y
semanas eso es lo que hacen los
estadounidenses
hace cuatro años respondí la llamada
para unirme a esto porque sabía que en
su creía en su liderazgo y en su visión
de hacer eeuu más grande en los últimos
cuatro años he visto a este presidente
recibir gran cantidad de ataques pero
levantarse para seguir luchando y
logrando las promesas que le hizo al
pueblo estadounidense así que con la
gratitud y la confianza que él me ha
dado el apoyo de nuestro partido
republicano y de dios'
aceptó la nominación para servir como
vicepresidente de eeuu
[Aplausos]
en esta oficina era un viaje que no me
esperaba es un viaje que no hubiera sido
posible sin el apoyo de mi familia
comenzando por mi esposa increíble
carmen
ella es una profesora una gran madre de
nuestros tres hijos
y es una sobresaliente segunda dama dama
de los eeuu
en wickford y no podríamos estar más
orgullosos de nuestros tres hijos
dennis wasser
nuestra hija charlotte
y esposa del teniente
y de nuestro más joven nuestra hija
y su prometido como muchos otros
estadounidenses tuvieron que posponer su
boda pero no podemos esperar para
quedarse aparte de nuestra familia
[Aplausos]
a esto se suman las personas la persona
que más me ha ayudado en esta vida mi
madre nancy
ella es la hija de un inmigrante
irlandés
mi madre sigue la política muy de cerca
y que la verdad sea dicha algunas veces
pero creo que soy su segundo candidato
favorito en esta carrera
pence gracias mamá te amo
en los últimos cuatro años tenía el
privilegio de trabajar cerca con nuestro
presidente y verlo cuando no hay cámaras
alrededor en eeuu
trump de diferentes maneras pero no hay
duda como trump de eeuu ve a estados
unidos por lo que es una nación que ha
hecho más bien que cualquiera en el
mundo una nación que merece mayor
gratitud y si quieren un presidente que
mantenga el silencio cuando insultan a
nuestro país pues este no va a ser su
presidente
s
en algunas personas creen que nosotros
somos diferentes
pero he aprendido algo al verlo
cómo trata todo lo que hemos vivido en
los últimos tres años y medio él hace
las cosas a su manera bajo sus propios
términos
casi nada pasa de largo y cuando tiene
una opinión
él no duda en decirlo él mantiene todo
interesante pero lo más importante
el presidente de donald trump ha
mantenido su palabra al pueblo de eeuu
en una ciudad conocida por habladores el
presidente de trump es alguien que hace
y muy pocos presidentes han traído mayor
independencia energía y determinación a
esa oficina
hace cuatro años se le damos un ejército
vacío
una economía luchando por salir hay
suscriptor del análisis controlaba
un terreno dos veces mayor que
pensilvania
vivimos amenazados nuestra libertad de
religión
a eso se enfrentó el presidente cuando
llegó hoy desde el primer día
reconstruyó nuestro ejército
este presidente firmó el mayor aumento
desde ronald reagan y creó la nueva rama
de fuerzas armadas en 70 años por las
fuerzas espaciales de los eeuu
[Aplausos]
y con esa energía volvimos con nuestros
astronautas al espacio luego de cerca de
10 años
y luego de años de escándalo del cuidado
a los veteranos el presidente mantuvo su
palabra otra vez
reformamos en el sistema y ahora es
disponible para cualquier veterano en
eeuu
[Aplausos]
nuestras fuerzas armadas y veteranas y
veteranos son los héroes de nuestra
nación y mucho nos acompaña en el día de
hoy hoy tenemos cuatro personas que
recibieron la medalla de honor
[Aplausos]
que han recibido el corazón púrpura
una persona que recibió la estrella de
oro
y soldados heridos
y estamos honrados con su presencia y
les agradecemos por su servicio
[Aplausos]
como estos hemos defendido a nuestra
nación todos los días y con este
comandante mi jefe
hemos luchado
con los islamistas radicales en su
territorio
destruimos su califato y destruimos su
califato y destruimos y dimos de baja el
líder sin dar de baja a ningún
estadounidense y estuve allí cuando
presienten trump
la orden del mayor terrorista iraní
en la historia porque qasem soleimani ya
no está
acabó con su desordenado
deben saber que yo voy de cryptic
critico a trump por estas decisiones
decisiones que dieron fin a dos
terroristas mundiales pero no es
sorpresa porque joe biden se opuso a la
operación que dio de baja osama bin
laden
no es sorpresa que el secretario defensa
bajo la administración obama biden dijo
que había sido
ya que habías hecho todo el mal en la
política exterior en los últimos cuatro
años así que nos enfrentamos a nuestros
enemigos y nos paramos junto a nuestros
aliados
y así como cuando el trump movió la
embajada estadounidense a jerusalén
[Aplausos]
y reconociendo a israel como un estado
futuro más cercano a casa
[Aplausos]
apoyamos nuestro el sentido de la vida
right ons
y cuando se trata de la economía
el presidente de trump mantuvo su
palabra e hizo algo más e hicimos el
mayor recorte de impuestos
desatamos de energía eeuu
y luchamos por el libre comercio
jobs se ha creado 7 mil millones de
buenos empleos
inclusive miles de
empresas manufactureras en todo el
territorio estadounidense
el país se convirtió en exportador de
energía
el desempleo de los hispanos es el más
bajo en años
estoy orgulloso de decir que bajo el
presidente yo extendemos la tasa más
baja de desempleo
femenino en los últimos años
y cada vez más estadounidenses
trabajando en los últimos tres años
creamos la economía más fuerte y más
grande hicimos que eeuu volviera a ser
grande
y luego nos golpeó el coronavirus desde
china
antes del primer caso llegará a eeuu el
presidente tomó acción sin precedente y
suspendió todos los viajes desde china
la segunda economía más grande del mundo
esa acción salvó vidas estadounidenses y
después decir de primera mano nos compró
tiempo para lanzar la movilización más
grande desde la segunda guerra mundial
él dirigió
reuters ojos en una alianza con los
gobernadores de todo el país de ambos
partidos
en apoyo a la reinvención de las pruebas
hoy estamos haciendo más de 800.000
pruebas al día y hemos coordinado
miles de tours de kits de protección
para las personas que trabajan en la
salud de enfermeros y médicos
[Aplausos]
vendimos ventiladores en 100 días y
nadie que necesitaba un ventilador le
fue negado un ventilador en eeuu
[Aplausos]
construimos hospitales
hicimos un acuerdo para salvar más de 70
millones de empleos estadounidenses nos
estamos desarrollando tratamientos
terapéuticos como el plasma
convaleciente que está salvando vidas en
todo eeuu la semana pasada a joe biden
dijo
no mejor que come
no viene ningún milagro bueno yo parece
no entender es que eeuu es una nación de
milagros
y esté orgulloso de decir que estamos en
camino de tener la vacuna contra el
coronavirus a finales de este año
[Aplausos]
después de todo el sacrificio en este
año como ninguno ningún otro
estamos encontrando nuestra forma de
seguir adelante pero esta noche nuestros
corazones están con todos aquellos que
han perdido familiares o queridos y que
tienen familiares que están luchando
contra las enfermedades en este país
estamos de luto con aquellos que están
de luto
en esta noche sé que millones de
estadounidenses han sido golpeados y
nosotros oramos por ustedes
nuestro país
nos supera un tiempo así a no ser que
las personas se encuentren la fuerza
dentro de sí la respuesta de médicos
enfermeras y agricultores camioneros y
de todos los estadounidenses
que ponen la salud y la seguridad
primero no ha sido nada menos que un
acto heroico
[Aplausos]
veronica se pone su atuendo todos los
días
trabajando en uno de los hospitales más
concurridos de nueva york se mantuvo en
su trabajo trabajando por horas hasta
que su trabajo estaba hecho y volvía a
su barrio y ayudaba a vecinos y amigos
que lo necesitaban su hermano william es
un bombero de nueva york y los dos son
emblemas de los héroes que hay en este
país
están con nosotros aquí esta noche y les
digo a ellos ya todos ustedes ustedes se
han ganado la admiración del pueblo
estadounidense y siempre vamos a estar
agradecidos por su servicio y su cuidado
[Aplausos]
gracias al coraje compasión del pueblo
estadounidense estamos deteniendo
el esparcimiento y protegemos a los
vulnerables y estamos reabriendo eeuu
por los fundamentos que ha puesto el
presidente tronco
hemos ganado 9.3 millones de empleos en
los últimos tres meses solamente
y nos estamos reabriendo eeuu
estamos reabriendo las escuelas
usted orgulloso de decir que mi esposa
karen la profesora con la que estoy
casado va a volver a su clase la próxima
semana así como todos los otros
profesores heroicos el staff fue gracias
por estar allí para nuestros hijos vamos
a estar con ustedes en cada paso de este
camino
en los próximos días mientras reabrimos
eeuu nuevamente les prometo que vamos a
poner la seguridad y la sanidad primero
todos tenemos una lección que hacer
en noviembre 3 tienen que preguntarse a
quién en quien confían para reconstruir
la economía un político de carrera
o un líder que se ha probado que ha
creado la mayor economía del mundo la
elección es clara debe volver a eeuu más
grande necesitamos cuatro años más el
presidente de donald trump en la casa
blanca
[Aplausos]
mis compatriotas estamos pasando un
tiempo de prueba en medio de esta
pandemia mundial
mientras nuestra nación se está
recuperando
hemos visto violencia y caos en las
calles de nuestras principales ciudades
el presidente camps y yo siempre vamos a
apoyar el derecho de la sep pero de
protestar se pacíficamente
pero el caos y los disturbios no son las
pacíficas protestas
destruir estatuas no es libertad de
expresión aquellos que lo hagan van a
ser judicial izados
la semana pasada yo verdad no dijo ni
una sola palabra acerca de la violencia
y el caos en varias ciudades de este
país así que déjenme hacerle claros esto
la violencia debe detenerse ya sea a
mineápolis portland o que muchos héroes
han muerto defendiendo a nuestra nación
para ver a los estadounidenses unos
contra otros vamos a tener ley y orden
en las calles de nuestro país para todos
los estadounidenses de cada raza de cada
credo y de cada color
elpresidente trump y yo sabemos que las
mujeres y los hombres que usan el
uniforme de las autoridades son los
mejores
cada día cuando salen por la puerta
consideran las vidas de los demás más
importante que las de ellos mismos la
vida como dave para ser un oficial en el
departamento
de protección que fue asesinado durante
los disturbios en california
en el heroísmo de él es emblemático de
los héroes que sirven al país
angela te decimos a ti
que estamos de luto contigo y que eeuu
no va a olvidar ni va a fallar en honrar
al oficial de patrick under world
el estadounidense lo sabe
no debemos elegir entre apoyar a las
autoridades que no tenemos y apoyar a
nuestros vecinos afrodescendientes eddie
cage yo aprobar la educación más empleo
seguridad y desde el primer día de esta
administración hemos hecho las dos cosas
y vamos a seguir manteniendo la ley el
orden y seguir apoyando a las minorías a
los afrodescendientes durante en todo
este país durante cuatro años más
[Aplausos]
dice que eeuu es sistemáticamente
racista
y que las autoridades se han dado un
impulso varias
gigantes manuales
tienen una parcialidad en cuanto a
recortar los fondos para las policías él
dijo que sí absolutamente
sterling
tengo el número de serie
y la verdad es que ustedes no van a
estar seguros en eeuu de joe biden
bajo el presidente camps
siempre vamos a estar con aquellos que
están en la primera línea y no vamos a
desmantelar la policía no ahora ni nunca
incluso mis compatriotas estamos pasando
un tiempo de prueba pero pronto vamos a
tener un tiempo para escoger mucho
bahiense referido como él y no como un
candidato de transición y muchos
preguntan una transición a que no la
semana pasada los demócratas no hablaron
mucho sobre su agenda y si yo fuera uno
de ellos tampoco lo hubiera hecho
bernie sanders dijo a sus seguidores que
joe biden ser el presidente más liberal
de los tiempos modernos de hecho dijo
que muchas de las ideas por las que
luchaba
que hace algunos años eran consideradas
radicales y que ahora son comunes en el
partido demócrata en la raíz de su
agenda está la creencia que eeuu está
dirigido por envidia no aspiración que
millones de estadounidenses
recienten a sus vecinos en vez de amarse
creen que el gobierno debe estar en la
vida de todos
deben dictar cómo vivir como tienen su
vida como trabajan como deben criar a
nuestros hijos
versión de ver su agenda está basada en
un gobierno que controla todo
nuestra agenda está basada en la
libertad
[Aplausos]
el presidente trump recorta los
impuestos yo bailé pretende aumentarlos
cuando este presidente logra la
independencia energética
el presidente el vicepresidente biden
pretende eliminar el combustible fósil
lo que aumentaría el costo de las
familias trabajadores nosotros luchamos
por libre comercio
y luchó ante china y terminó con una era
económica sometida
él quiere
en crítica al presidente de trammo por
suspender todos los viajes a china
cuando inició esta pandemia joe biden es
para abrir fronteras y liberar abogados
e inmigrantes
y construyó 300.000 millas de ese muro
para proteger a estados unidos
el presidente cree que cualquier padre
debe tener el derecho de elegir a qué
escuela debe ir sin importar sus
ingresos o su lugar de residencia
el presidente trump
ha apoyado la vida yo bailé y yo bailé
en el apoyo
los fondos para los abortos cuando
ustedes consideran su agenda es clara
joe biden no va a ser nada más que un
caballo de troya para la izquierda
radical elección nunca ha sido más clara
en las apuestas no han sido más altas la
semana pasada vaivén lo que la
democracia la democracia está en juego y
que nuestra economía está en este voto
pero hay cosas más importantes y
fundamentales para nuestro país
esta elección no es sobre si eeuu era
más liberal o más conservador más
republicano o más demócrata
la elección va a ser si estados unidos
se mantiene siendo eeuu
si le vamos a dejar a nuestros hijos y
nietos un país con los más altos ideales
de libertad comercios libertad de
comercio y les vamos a dejar que ha sido
fundamentalmente transformado en otra
cosa
estamos en una encrucijada eeuu el
presidente trump está en un camino de
oportunidad de libertad joe biden diría
y nos llevaría en un camino de
declinación
pero no vamos a dejar que eso suceda
el presidente de donald trump cree en
eeuu y en el pueblo de eeuu en el
potencial de vivir su sueño en libertad
el presidente está lucha cada día por
mantener la promesa de eeuu todos los
días nuestro presidente luchó para
expandir
el alcance del sueño estadounidense cada
día
el presidente lucha por ustedes
y ahora es nuestro turno de luchar por
él
en esta noche acompañado por estos
héroes
estoy muy agradecido del privilegio de
servir como vicepresidente esta gran
nación y de tener la oportunidad de
volver a servir
voy a entregar todo para ese deber en el
año 2020
el pueblo estadounidense ha tenido una
gran cantidad de retos pero gracias y
tenemos un presidente que tiene la
determinación y la resolución para
llevarnos adelante